>> You know, we have today the highest level
of unemployment ever
recorded.
And the highest level of youth unemployment
ever recorded with three
times higher than adults in many countries
and in some regions
50 percent of all unemployment.
And we are facing a jobless recovery in a
number of countries.
So the key question is put job creation at
the center of the recovery.
How could I put it politically?
We need to put the same policy decisiveness,
the same creativity, the
same capacity for out-of-the-box thinking
that went into saving banks,
into saving jobs, into creating jobs into
the investment process that
necessary and also for youth employment.
How do we do it?
We can't repeat the mistakes of the past.
We're not going to get out of the crisis by
repeating the policies that
led us into the crisis.
So the International Labor Organization has
put the policy of global
jobs back to be able to address in a primary
and a fundamental way the
issues of jobs and particularly for youth.